I'm persuaded that there should be no
postulates or principles that act the
same ways
physical fury maybe and so therefore
it's
an emergent but let's let's take up my
fermions don't make moral judgments
people do in particular to the brain
part of people it is so if I make if I
make a particular judgment it's a moral
judgment is not an uncool bunch of stuff
goes into that I could write a computer
program probably those sub components
those you probably would concede I can
study using naturalistic inquiry so is
it is there that much of a disconnection
between studying individuals and making
a moral judgment and then generalizing
because then we're in a different then
it's emergent in the sense of
discontinued there's a discontinuity
between talking about individual
psychology and morality in the group
which yeah puzzling to me well I don't
it's not but it's it's troubling because
and I actually do think we could study
an individual let's say Stephen says he
wants to help you know his department or
his family we can figure that it means
you draw on your memory on your
perceptual approach on decision making
and we take all those things to be part
of psychology that we can in fact study
in a completely naturalistic way we can
certainly study what people do in a
completely naturalistic way and then
there's looting there including their
moral judgments but then it's a
different question about how you would
study what people should be doing and I
think but if it's very well in as Terry
is pointing out with I mean there's a
reason why we had yesterday's discussion
in today's discussion I I would say the
right way to think about everything
we're saying here at is as an emergent
set of phenomena and I would say the way
I like to talk about is what we were
calling levels or scales or whatever are
just different models different theories
different vocabularies different
ontologies if you want to go that far
for talking about the same underlying
reality and the point of today's
discussion I would I would say has been
that or I didn't even say stories or
narratives just to just Alex so we have
a story that we tell about atoms we have
a story that we tell about fluids we
have a story then we call about human
beings in their psychology we have a
story we tell about right and wrong and
the difference is that we choose which
stories to believe in to
tell each other and to proceed on the
basis of in a different way when they're
purely descriptive scientific stories
than when they're moral stories when we
when we attach meaning nosov this is a
good act or a bad act whether you want
to call it moral or not I kind of agree
with Steve that there's not much of a
distinction it's just a vocabulary
distinction so we're deciding whether or
not in in the emergent behavior of human
beings to label a certain thing bad
morally bad or morally good and the
basis on which we make that choice I
think as we're saying here is a
different kind of basis than the
evidentiary scientific hypothesis
testing basis it's one that says well we
all have certain beliefs we all have
certain inclinations and we're trying to
reconcile them and communicate about
them and tell each other compelling
narratives and and things like that but
recognizing that distinction leaves a
narratives not subject the same kind of
inquiry no I mean I would say that if if
someone says that parking in a
handicapped space to save yourself a
little bit of time going to the grocery
store is okay I absolutely deny that
they are wrong in the same sense as
someone who says the universe is not
expanding is wrong they're both wrong
but in completely different senses one
is just objectively wrong because
they're getting the universe wrong one I
believe is wrong and would try to
persuade you is wrong on the basis of my
moral judgments that hopefully I overlap
with you enough to make that case
you